now that we're in 2021 apple's m1 max
have proven to be
incredibly powerful for the price but
what happens when we put
the absolute least expensive macbook
the 999 dollar base m1 macbook air up
against
the absolute most expensive macbook
the 3899 16 inch macbook pro
with the 8 core i9 2.4 gig processor
and the insane 5600 am graphics chip
which by the way was a major improvement
over the previous graphics options now
this comparison
is just a bit insane because the 16 inch
is basically
four times more expensive it's a much
larger machine in general and it has
two cooling fans well the macbook air
has
zero but what if the air
could actually compete in some areas if
it can
it'll prove just how good apple silicon
really is
and it'll give us a sneak peek at the
potential performance
of the upcoming 14 and 16 inch m1x
macbook pros
which are expected to boost the market
share of apple silicon max
all the way up to 7 so let's get right
into the performance testing
with geekbench 5. in terms of single
core cpu performance
the m1 air is way ahead because it uses
only four
very powerful and efficient performance
cores
and making it even more surprising the
m1 air
actually outperforms the 16-inch in
terms of multi-core performance as well
now if we go over to real world
performance using the 10 minute
cinebench r23 stress test
the 16 inch now takes over by a huge 38
percent
because the air has no fans at all so it
starts to throttle down the performance
so in terms of cpu power the air is
better
for short bursts of performance while
the 16 inch is better for
longer and heavier workloads which we'll
get into in just a second
but now i want to move on to graphics
performance and this is where the
16 inch pro's 5600 m gpu
really shines being over twice as fast
as the base 7 core gpu on the m1 air
in terms of geekbench 5 metal
performance this is going to impact
everything from
gaming to video editing performance but
we've actually estimated
that the future m1x 16-inch pro with the
integrated
16 core gpu is gonna beat the current
dedicated 5600 m graphics so that's very
exciting
now moving on to gaming performance we
tested gfx bench 5.0
using the aztec runes off-screen test
and here
there isn't as big of a difference but
the 16-inch is still
95 more powerful than the air which is a
big deal for gaming
we also tested games like league of
legends where the m1 air was able to
maintain
an average of 82 frames per second but
it's still
nothing compared to the 16 inch and then
in fortnight
the air had less than 60 fps average so
it couldn't keep up with the 16 inch pro
which got very good frame rates now on
top of that you have to use workarounds
like crossover and parallel 16 to run
windows games on the m1 and a lot of
them won't even run
while the 16 inch can easily use boot
camp which performs
much better and more reliably so it's
very clear which one is better for
gaming
now since the m1x 16 inch is expected to
have more graphics power
than the 5600m we should actually get
very great aaa gaming results later this
year
and hopefully a lot of the bugs in
crossover and other apps will be fixed
by then
i personally think that a lot of people
will eventually start to prefer
macs over windows laptops for gaming
so it's going to be very interesting to
see what's going to happen over the next
couple of years
moving on let's focus on a variety of
common tasks for mac users
like photo editing xcode programming and
logic pro music production
so let's start with the latter we tested
the new logic pro benchmark
which measures how many tracks the
machine can run without overloading the
cpu
and surprisingly the macbook air was
right behind the 16-inch pro
which nobody was expecting because of
the huge difference
in raw multi-core performance so for
people who are producing music
the new m1 air is actually a killer
value
and the upcoming m1x max are gonna be
just insane now moving on to xcode
programming
this is where i was absolutely blown
away
the m1 macbook air destroyed the 16-inch
pro
being a massive 80 faster
which doesn't make any sense if you look
at the previous results
and it even did it without a fan while
the 16 inch was loud and very hot
i personally think that this is because
of the more efficient and optimized
arm-based
architecture including the unified
memory
even though it only has 8 gigs of ram
compared to
32 gigs on the 16 inch so the future is
looking
very bright for programmers now let's
get into photo editing with lightroom
classic
which by the way hasn't been updated for
apple silicon
just yet so it's using rosetta to run
we exported 50 raw 42 megapixel photos
and the air is performing surprisingly
well
being only 38 seconds slower than the
16-inch pro
even though it has 4 times less ram
however
when we bump up this test to 500 raw
photos
instead of just 50 the macbook air
begins to suffer
from thermal throttling because of the
lack of a fan
and the difference becomes much bigger
with the 16 inch being around 8 minutes
faster but in terms of editing
smoothness the
m1 is still very quick and snappy
because of the arm chip
so it really only makes a difference
when exporting photos
so if you work with very large projects
the 16 inch is still the way to go now
let's finally get into video editing
with final cut pro
starting with the bruce x benchmark
which fully relies on graphics power
and the 6-inch pro was three times
faster
which is extremely impressive then
moving on to exporting a 5-minute 4k
h.264 clip which is the most common
format that most youtubers use
the 16 inch was only 3 seconds faster
than the air
and that's because this test is mostly
limited by the hardware encoders
and the ones on the m1 are faster next
up we have a couple of stabilization
tests
starting with stabilizing a 1 minute
hevc clip
and surprisingly they both finished in
just 10 seconds
once again limited by the encoders but
now when stabilizing c200
canon raw footage the 16 inch is quite a
bit ahead
because there are no encoders for this
type of footage
so it depends on a mixture of cpu and
gpu performance
moving on i decided to test some very
heavy footage
exporting a 5 minute 8k redraw clip
and here the difference is massive with
the 16 inch being over
three times as fast because of the extra
graphics performance
and the fact that it actually has fans
so if you're doing
any kind of heavy video editing the 16
inch is currently
the better option for sure now i want to
finish off with
one test which was heavily requested
transcoding and exporting
the new canon r5 10-bit 422 footage
surprisingly the macbook air absolutely
destroyed the 16-inch
in terms of the 5-minute export test and
that's because
the m1 max are currently the only
computers in the world
that have hardware encoders and decoders
for this new codec now if you choose to
transcode this footage
instead the massive difference remains
with the m1 air only taking
13 minutes to transcode a 30 minute clip
compared to 40 minutes for the 16 inch
macbook pro
which is just insane so with all of that
testing out of the way
i want to remind you guys that this is
the absolute
weakest apple silicon macbook that will
ever be made
compared to the absolute most powerful
intel macbook
ever made you can quite literally buy
four of these macbook airs
for the same price of this 16-inch pro
and amazingly when it comes to
real-world performance
the air isn't as far off as you'd expect
it to be and there's absolutely
no fan noise at all and in some of these
tests like
xcode programming and canon r5 video
editing
the air was actually faster and one
thing to keep in mind
is that the m1 chip uses much less power
only 13 watts for the cpu compared to
60 on the 16 inch and 5.6 watts for the
graphics
compared to 50 watts for the 5600 m gpu
so if you get anything out of this
comparison video you should be
extremely excited for the 16 inch m1x
macbook pro
that's coming later this year because
that macbook
is gonna be insane likely with four
extra high performance cores and 8 extra
gpu cores
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and tap the like
button below
and click the circle above to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there
and we will see you in the next one